a esta hora los conductores de uber en
el reino unido celebran esta decisión
que ha sido considerada histórica en una
larga batalla judicial se estima que 45
mil conductores están vinculados a esta
plataforma aquí en el regido las
implicaciones son varias primero para
über la compañía directamente ahora que
tendrá que pagar en derechos laborales a
sus empleados tendrá que considerar como
parte de la organización tendrá que
pagar de vacaciones los derechos a la
salud en caso de que se enfermen y otro
tipo de derechos laborales para los
consumidores seguramente el servicio de
mujer aumentará y habría menos oferta
aunque ahora que son empleados
directamente contratados había menos
conductores disponibles también tiene
implicaciones para la economía informal
en el reino unido uber no solamente
presta el servicio de transporte de
pasajeros sino también de domicilios y
por supuesto para las aplicaciones
porque el modelo de negocio se impacta
directamente con
decisión y seguramente la decisión
judicial que se ha tomado hoy aquí en el
reino unido- motivar a que conductores
en otras ciudades del mundo busquen este
tipo de derechos